as we continue our coverage of the
horrific
shooting here at uvalde in uvalde texas
at robb elementary school at least 21
people killed 19 of them children for
more on the investigation and exactly
what happened here in the school behind
me we're joined now by lieutenant chris
oliveiras of the texas department of
public safety uh lieutenant you were
telling me that the shooter uh drove his
vehicle into a ditch not far from where
we're standing tried to enter the school
and met resistance from law enforcement
right away that's correct so prior to
that though
the shooter was involved in a domestic
disturbance with his grandmother we do
know that he was living with his
grandparents and was involved in some
type of domestic disturbance with his
grandmother in which he shot his own
grandmother at that point he fled from
that residence to the area where the
school's at that's where the vehicle was
crashed and he was able to make entry
into the school that's when we got calls
from local law enforcement that the
shooter was making his way into the
school so he meets resistance from law
enforcement at the gate fights his way
in once he's inside the school what
happens right so we had local police
officers here from the uvalde police
department school police officers as
well as state troopers that were
responded on scene first they were the
primary officers on scene they heard the
gunfire they saw the shooter at that
point they were met with gunfire by the
shooter several police officers were
shot
um at that point the gunman the shooter
was able to make entry into a classroom
barricaded himself and at that point it
just started shooting children and
teachers that were inside that classroom
having no regard for human life just a
complete tragedy and an evil person uh
going into this school and killing
children for no for no reason whatsoever
how was law enforcement eventually able
to breach that classroom and take out
the shooter right so at that point the
initial officers that were on scene
they're at a point of disadvantage there
was no way they were able to make entry
especially with the amount of manpower
that was on scene so at that point their
primary focus was to evacuate as many
children as possible
teachers they were breaking windows
around the school trying to evacuate
children to prevent any for the loss of
life but again they kept hearing the
gunfire as they were doing this as they
were performing these rescues we had a
specialized tactical law enforcement
team arrived comprised of federal law
enforcement local law enforcement state
law enforcement that were able to make
forcible entry into that classroom and
just goes to show you that placing their
own lives between the shooter and those
children to try to prevent any for the
loss of life as they entered that
classroom one of those officers was met
with gunfire he was hit he was shot
he is out of the hospital at that point
they were able to shoot and kill the
shooter and prevent any for the loss of
lice it's so scary to think this could
have been even worse than what it was so
so that's the how what about the why
what do we know at this hour the shooter
kills or attempts to kill his
grandmother she's clinging to life at
the moment and then drives here was this
a target premeditated or just what he
saw next you know that's why we're still
trying to determine exactly what the
motives were what the indicators were if
there was any red flags prior to this
mass shooting we are working with our
fbi partners atf local law enforcement
as well as with the school our texas
rangers right now are the lead
investigating agency but we're trying to
determine that we know right now that
this individual the shooter did reside
in the uvalde area did attend a local
high school was living with his
grandparents
no friends no girlfriends at this time
that we know of was unemployed no
criminal history no gang affiliation so
we're trying to determine exactly what
the motive was and what any indicators
at all whatsoever uh prior to the
shooting and so he he does this with an
assault style rifle an ar-15 style rifle
uh how is he able to obtain that uh what
are the rules around here right
acquisition that's a good question so
exactly we're trying to determine
exactly how he obtained this rifle um
how it was purchased when it was
purchased so that's why we have atf
working closely with our texas rangers
trying to make that determination again
as i mentioned no criminal history no
gang affiliation so again trying to
determine exactly how he was able to
purchase this rifle the capacity the
type of rifle that he was in possession
of all right lieutenant oliveira is
we're so grateful to law enforcement for
stopping this knowing it could have been
even worse right exactly very much thank
you